buenos días todo va quedando listo para
la transmisión de mando
manuel merino convocó al parlamento a
sesión solemne a las 10 de la mañana de
hoy para su juramentación como un nuevo
presidente de este país a través de las
redes sociales diversos colectivos están
convocando a marchas de protesta en las
plazas de todo el país en rechazo al
congreso y también a manuel merino
porque ellos no están de acuerdo con la
destitución de martín vizcarra por su
parte diversos gremios empresariales a
través de un comunicado hicieron un
llamado a las autoridades y también a la
ciudadanía para conservar la serenidad y
la estabilidad que garanticen la
gobernabilidad en el país